el 16 de febrero será recordado en
España como un día de conquistas
feministas así lo dijo la ministra de
igualdad española Irene Montero tras la
aprobación de dos de sus leyes estrella
por un lado la reforma de la ley de
salud sexual y reproductiva que
introduce por primera vez en Europa
bajas laborales remuneradas para mujeres
con dolores menstruales incapacitantes
además de educación sexual en escuelas
en toda la etapa obligatoria de
Educación Asimismo elimina la necesidad
del permiso parental para las jóvenes de
16 y 17 años que quieran abortar y
blinda la ley contra protocolos que
pretendan disuadir a una mujer con
respecto a su decisión de abortar por
otro lado se aprobó la ley trans que
abre la puerta a la autodeterminación de
género desde los 16 años sin requisitos
y entre los 12 y los 16 con autorización
o judicial o parental una ley que
también prohíbe las mal llamadas
terapias de conversión y que según el
colectivo era una deuda pendiente del
Estado español Aunque piden que esta se
traduzca en derechos reales
porque han sido muchos años para
conseguir una legislación para las
patologías y la libertad la libre
determinación de las personas trans y
del colectivo lgtbi también porque
también la norma nos apoya y nos da
derecho es un día de alegría es un día
para celebrar y las sensaciones Son
miles miles de sensaciones de alegría y
de emoción tenemos una buena base para
seguir avanzando y esta ley también nos
va a permitir el que se concreten
políticas activas en el empleo para las
personas porque es una lacra que nos que
nos no estamos hablando de paro no
estamos hablando de exclusión estamos
hablando de aparcel laboral finaliza así
un largo y complicado trámite
legislativo que ha causado la escisión
del movimiento feminista que de nuevo
este año Así como lo hizo en 2022
marchará en dos manifestaciones
separadas durante el 8 de marzo Día
Internacional de la mujer mientras tanto
más del 60% de la población española
respalda la necesidad de otorgar más
derechos al colectivo lgbtiq más